first of all I want to talk to you guys
about Kickstarter feel like this
conversation happens like every couple
of months some dumb nonsense happens and
some real dumb nonsense happens over the
past two days and there was an article I
read a rock paper shotgun which I think
was pulled not from maybe GamesRadar or
someone basically talking about news
video Peter Molyneux on the status of
Goddess which was his Kickstarter
populist esque sort of spiritual
successor as it were yeah sounds like
that game has come to a complete
development like stop or they at least
have like had to replace and staffers
and that whatever they promised is now
I'm not going to come to fruition yeah I
think it's unfair to call it purely a
Kickstarter problem i Peter Molyneux is
isn't genius he does have wonderful
ideas we've seen a lot of his ideas not
come to complete fruition yeah and we've
seen recently goddess the game that he
did originally start on Kickstarter a
lot of the key team members have left
we're actually talking with some of them
now we're gonna we're looking into that
and seeing like what is gonna happen to
this okay it was one of those that he
had grant a grand vision laid that on
Kickstarter promised a whole lot of
stuff and none of those things it really
had did the whole thing with like some
person won a contest and was the god yes
in your world for like a period of time
until they were usurped that was the
curiosity cube iphone app the day I had
their ever wonder who in fact was
somebody who downloaded that morning
yeah and I didn't know what really what
it was yeah yeah just so what happened
was this came out I guess the the
article or PS was yesterday and then
when I woke up this morning I realized
the 22cans had actually posted up
perhaps one of the most cringey
confessional videos I've ever seen in my
life with Peter Molyneux and I think a
gentleman who is the new lead for
goddess and some another gentleman from
22cans basically going through the
reasons people are worried about this
and some of the quotes from what I have
to say we're just a little bit a bit
crazy my morning brain could barely deal
with it as suffice to say the goddess
Kickstarter will not be fulfilled in the
team of either quit their job
or have been moved which was an
anonymous source to came out in that
article but Mr mana you had a bunch
himself the art book we haven't done
that and that's primarily because we've
been so busy the problem with the
multiplayer is when you develop features
you need to also make sure they are
multiplayer compatible so much bear
these are part of the stretch goals
haven't been done and the next step for
us is adding combat after that we should
have a look at multiplayer again and one
of the worst ones i think is now i'm not
worried about the pledges i do worry
about the linux version pledge because
we need to and we need the middleware
that we use marmalades to update to
support linux linux which are currently
does not which was another stretch goal
that they achieve so and it just seems
like a planning [ __ ] across the
ball that's something Kickstarter is a
platform that lets someone even an
experienced developer like Peter
Molyneux to say to I mean anything that
I'm gonna do here's something here's the
things that I want to deliver but you
don't have a finished product like
you're basically bankrolling I mean
you're being the publisher in this kind
of instance and you're saying here's I'm
gonna give you guys money because I like
that idea and you hope that it gets
delivered and I think it's weird when
people think of it as an investment and
I've heard that thrown around a lot like
people feel like they're investing in
the product that's being created but I
mean really you're pre-ordering again
but you're pre-ordering before it's even
created normally we have the buffer of a
publisher who's fronting the money who's
making sure that it gets developed and
that it's you know product that's going
to work in this case we're bankrolling
the game being created in most cases
sometimes the games are done and they
just want to bring it to more platforms
or they want to expand the reach in some
way and in this case we were basically
bankrolling goddess as a project and
most of those things aren't gonna be
delivered on which is something that is
it's a danger with any Kickstarter
project whether it's a game or not when
they have these are basically ideas and
they want to make these come to fruition
like sometimes they're like there are
some products and you have to be really
careful there was one that I was
watching and I was really weary of last
year it was a tracking device that
didn't use a battery that didn't require
anything but it would tide your phone
and you could like slip it in your wall
is what it says it's like this little
device put it in your wallet you'll be
able to track it no matter where it's at
that sounds like too good to be true it
does like wow this is really interesting
and so I it's powered by
wishes well I mean there are you know
like the NFC readers those those cards
days they interact with devices but the
problem is that this is saying that even
if you're not nearby even if your phone
is not nearby you'd be able to find out
where it says was this total nonsense
and it was a complete buck it was
sounded really cool I'd put on a little
reminder I'm like I'm gonna check that
on this but surely like it's worse when
somebody like Peter male who has been
involved in like publishing massive like
games like black and white in the fable
series when they you want to trust them
and even want to someone like Peter
money who was consistently you know
falling short of his own lofty
expectations and we kind of love him for
that but it's it not just simply false
advertising like this isn't the first
time I top of the other space space at
DF nine last year with Double Fine was
another game that was at on early access
that promised all of these features and
then eventually through I imagine just
the wheels of game development at a
certain stage you realize you know the
game that you had on paper at the start
wasn't the game that it was going to be
at the end but it's different when
people have bought the idea of the game
you said you were going to make and
that's the thing what's with terms like
false advertising and you buy the idea
of it I think we're so used to consuming
games when you know we look at a feature
list we read about the features and we
understand we can visualize what that's
going to be in and that's describing a
game that exists yeah but when you're
reading on Kickstarter you're not
describing something that exists you're
describing the dreams that exist the
plans that exist and I think Justin your
analogy to a person funding on
kickstarter being the publisher it you
know look at video game publishers over
the past 5 10 years how many of them
have gone out of business compared to
how many are still in business how many
of had to drastically change their plans
how many are scrambling to do DLC this
and that because the publishing business
is volatile and uncertain men that's
kind of the way it is when you're
betting on stuff on Kickstarter I wonder
like is this just a case of like caveat
emptor like should people just be wary
of the money that they're investing in
or do we need to have like especially
companies that are established and have
been releasing games like do they need
to do a better job as doing good on this
or should they just stop asking for
money before their game has even started
being made
I love the idea of Kickstarter and how
it does both empower the developer I
just notice you're reading rainbow cup
yeah I inadvertently brought my reading
ring but like this is another thing that
that I backed as a Kickstarter like
levar burton put together this reading
rainbow program we want to bring that
back in as a program that didn't wasn't
getting the funding that it used to
wanted to bring that back bring it out
to schools and it's something that
raised a lot of money and you know if
you back that you could choose to get a
cup like oh cool i'll get a coffee mug
feel like I'm doing something good for
the world and he got a lot of flack for
people saying well you're actually
making money from this too much his
responses will no [ __ ] this is also part
of my job like I want to make money from
this I want to make it something
lucrative in something that's going to
be able to work as a business idea and
and some people i don't feel like
totally understand what they're getting
into with these Kickstarter's it's
getting back to that i think i'm
investing in a game that i'm going to be
a part of this game when actually you're
just kind of giving the money to end
hoping that they're going to deliver on
those promises and no you should always
be careful with where you invest your
money whether that's a pre-order that
you're making for a game whether it's a
game that's already out and you're
buying or whether it's the idea of a
game like on Kickstarter that like that
is a lot at your discretion and a i
don't i don't think that it's
necessarily on a system like Kickstarter
to to try to close that off more like I
think that we do look after ourselves a
lot but you I trust the people that I
follow on kik started like they kind of
alert me when there's a cool or a good
idea out there yeah and if I'm not a
hundred percent behind it maybe I like I
said a reminder and I'll come back and
check on it see what people are saying
in the comments seeing how those
companies respond both to come like how
how involved are they with the community
giving me updates about what's going on
and that's going to be a good indication
of how they're gonna you know progress
along when they actually have something
to work on but but even then like
there's always a little bit of a danger
but I like that I wouldn't want to take
that away because either you like the
the race early age I don't invest in
stuff that I'm really really interested
in that I really really want because I'm
so worried about getting let down like I
I try not to investing games are on
there because sort of being on this side
of the the price as well but like for
instance neverending nightmares was a
game that I really wanted to see get
made like I thought I'd touched up on
stuff that I like I wanted to have a
game made about like anxiety and
depression
not and I'm when I getting kamesh like
yeah it was it was what it said it was
and I enjoyed it but I kind of would
have been happy anyway and then I
kick-started stuff like books like it
was a sensible software book that was
getting made I was like yeah that's not
going to get made unless people wanted
ahead of time because you know I mean
that's the other thing that were
specific like and that sort of stuff
good but the games I really really want
like I just I'm so worried the
difference between the game in the book
at that point I mean you're talking
about a product that doesn't exist
you're talking about also like are you
saying it was a foregone conclusion that
neverending nightmares was gonna get
made no because does someone was already
developing it like what's where where's
the difference for you there i guess i
was i was using both of those as tip
jars for ideas that i actually wanted
like i haven't read the book it looks
great on my shelf and i'm really happy
it got made but i guess yeah like maybe
it's just something like I'm very wary
of early access as well but it's it's a
way for especially developers who don't
have a publisher behind them to say like
is anyone interested in in me creating
this thing and I actually back a lot of
board games that aren't going to get a
big release because it's expensive to
ship those out to stores to have that
stock of them and sometimes those board
games they create are basically we're
doing a one-off thing if you guys give
us enough money we'll make it and we
ship it out to you and that's basically
it and it it's a kind of a proving
ground for like do people care about
this is this gonna be fun and
interesting and I'm willing to try that
out and yes I'm sure I've kick-started
some crappy board games but I learned
some really fun ones as well I think the
bottom line is like you said Danny
caveat emptor I mean this is not Rita
like we live in a world where you know
we are used to buying stuff from Amazon
or wherever where there are these
systems in place to ensure customer
satisfaction and companies have the you
know that built into their business plan
this is not buying something that exists
this is not protect you can't go to a
better business bureau and be like hey
these guys are straight up making
fraudulent claims about the thing that's
on their shelf like it's a plumber plums
my house with chocolate tubes yeah it
isn't it's a different thing and you
gotta wrap your head around it before
you go in there so you manage your
expectations we're getting into yeah
well peter molyneux ask for money for
goddess and 22cans we'll have to wait
and see whether his next project which
he is already talking about goes down
the Kickstarter route something tells me
that if it does maybe it won't be
successful and let us know what you
think about Kickstarter and
sting in the comments below books